16 heures donc nous auditionnons le
ministre maintenant de 14 heures à 15
heures nous reprendrons l'examen du
texte à 17 heures pour la discussion en
général et l'examen des amendements
voilà donc tel est le cadre de nos
discussions donc monsieur le ministre je
vais vous donner immédiatement la parole
et puis la parole sera à la salle pour
un certain nombre de questions sachant
que cette audition et ramasser jusqu'à
15 heures je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre à madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous voici à nouveau réunis pour
la neuvième fois autour de l'examen d'un
projet de loi de gestion des crises
sanitaires
cette nouvelle mobilisation du parlement
allait fondamental pour répondre à une
reprise épidémique qui est causé par un
ennemi que nous connaissons désormais
bien le variant delta qui est un variant
extrêmement contagieux et qui est en
train de déclencher dans notre pays
comme dans d'autres pays autour de nous
une quatrième vague et ce en pleine
période estivale
j'ai envie de vous dire que cette
épidémie a plusieurs particularités
d'ailleurs d'abord c'est une épidémie
qui touche essentiellement les jeunes de
20 à 40 ans avec des taux d'incidence
chez les 20 30 ans dans certains
départements qui sont beaucoup plus
élevés que ce que nous avons connu
jusqu'à présent
c'est une épidémie qui est mondiale avec
ce variant delta nombre de pays autour
de nous mais aussi en australie et sont
bien des continents je pense à la
tunisie sont actuellement sujets à une
tension sanitaires extrêmement forte et
où une circulation de virus y compris
dans les endroits je lisais reculer et
dans lesquels jusqu'ici le virus avait
été plutôt épargnants notamment d'acide
contenu la situation insulaire
c'est une épidémie qui peut se propager
à une vitesse assez fulgurante
il en veut pour preuve dans certains
départements d augmentation de la
circulation du virus de plusieurs
centaines de % en seulement une semaine
avec un temps doublement du virus qui
est beaucoup plus court que ce que nous
avions connu avec le kobe de 19 et les
variants anglais sud africain et c'est
que vous avez pu connaître une épidémie
qui porteraient une part d'incertitude
car à date est on est que malgré tout ce
variant reste assez récent il est
difficile d'avoir une vision très claire
sur l'impact sanitaire qui peut
déclencher une vague épidémique dans
pays qui ont déjà vaccinées tout ou
partie de leur population je vois que en
angleterre alors qu'ils sont maintenant
bientôt à 50 mille cas par jour l'impact
sanitaire est décorrélé certes de
l'impact épidémique mais l'impact
sanitaire est réel et en france nous
avons déjà une augmentation depuis 10
jours consécutifs du nombre d'admissions
à l'hôpital du nombre d'interventions
d'urgence et une augmentation des
admissions dans les réanimations pour
des cas graves qui sont les personnes
qui m'ont à l'hôpital aujourd'hui ce
sont très rarement les jeunes qui sont
pourtant des plus touchés par le virus
parce que la même manière qu'avec les
anciennes les anciens variant les jeunes
font peu de formes graves
sally les jeunes peuvent faire des
copies de long ils peuvent être
extrêmement lourdement handicapés dans
leur santé pendant des semaines ou des
mois après avoir une affection peu
sévère non les personnes qu'on va voir
arriver à l'hôpital est en réanimation
pour l'essentiel sont des gens qui
portent des fragilités des maladies des
comorbidités ou qui sont d'un âge avancé
qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés c'est
le cas de 15% de la population âgée ou
porteuses de maladies dans notre pays
encore et si je devais vous donnez une
comparaison je vous rappellerai qu'au
cours de la première vague qui a mis en
tension comme jamais nos hôpitaux
seuls 2 à 4% de la population étaient
touchés par le virus si je vous dis
qu'on a encore ne serait-ce que 15% de
la population fragile qui n'est pas
vaccinée ça veut tout dire de ce qui
peut se passer si une vague devenait
très forte dans notre pays nous avons
des projections comme d'habitude de
l'institut pasteur des modélisateurs qui
laisse à penser que à la fin du mois
d'août nous pourrions connaître une
vague sanitaire important mais la
situation je disais est différente par
rapport à ce que nous avons pu connaître
auparavant parce que nous avons
évidemment une nouvelle arme c'est le
vaccin ces vaccins qui est efficace kit
proposé partout pour tous tout le temps
avec un rythme de vaccination que le
pays n'avait jamais connu des records
hebdomadaire qui permet au plus grand
nombre d'accéder de se protéger
progressivement contre contre se mariant
le vaccin est efficace contre la variole
le vaccin de propre ne ne provoque pas
la maladie le vaccin protège de la
maladie le protège des formes graves à
tout âge et le vaccin permet de diminuer
la contagiosité enfin la circulation du
virus et donc de limiter l'impact des
vagues
épidémique je les dis un plus de 95% des
patients actuellement hospitalisé pour
cas graves sont des gens qui n'ont pas
terminé leur cycle vaccinale quatre
millions de personnes sont décédées du
colis de 19 à travers le monde depuis le
début de la pandémie notamment dans les
pays où les vaccins ne sont pas
accessibles actuellement mais aussi des
pays dans lesquels la gratuité des soins
n'est pas la norme et la gratuité des
tests n'est pas la norme
ça fait plus de vingt ans que les
vaccins sont développés avec cette
technologie
certes les vagues ça antico vides ont un
peu plus d'un an
mais les contre indications sont connus
identifier elle se réduit d'ailleurs
comme peau de chagrin au fil de
l'observation envie réelle de la
vaccination et le bilan
bénéfices/risques est très en faveur de
la vaccination traite en faveur pour
toutes ces raisons gouvernement ne peut
se résoudre à constater que 40 % des
professionnels de santé en première
ligne sur la gestion de crise et avec
toute la reconnaissance légitime qu'on
leur doit
pour le l'action qui réalise depuis plus
d'un an et demi pour sauver des vies
soigner les malades
le gouvernement ne peut se résoudre de
constater que encore 40% d'entre eux ne
sont pas vaccinés la couverture
vaccinale des soignants est plus faible
que celle de la population générale
notamment en ehpad
alors que la possibilité de se faire
vacciner leur est offert depuis le mois
de janvier sur leur lieu de travail en
centre père médecin chez leur pharmacien
80 plus de 80 % des résidents
d'établissements pour personnes âgées
sont complètement vaccinés contre le coc
vide et 1,4 million de soignants sont
concernés par cette nécessité de se
vacciner
l'une des principales mesures portées
par ce projet de loi est donc
précisément cette obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants ou personnels
exerçant leurs activités au sein d'un
établissement de santé
nous voulons faire des hôpitaux et des
ehpad des sanctuaires
orco vide nous voulons que lorsqu'un
patient est hospitalisé pour un cancer
pour une maladie infectieuse pour un
infarctus qu'il est admis en ehpad parce
qu'il est il est en perte d'autonomie
qui est très sage et très fragile
nous voulons que ces personnes soient
sur soi sur
1 2 ne soit pas l'endroit pourrait être
contaminé par le covin cette obligation
vaccinale sera applicable à partir du 15
septembre pour laisser le temps à
l'ensemble des professionnels de se
conformer à cette obligation
il y aura des autorisations d'absence
sans impact sur la rémunération pour les
soignants pour qu'ils puissent aller se
faire vacciner et le contrôle de cette
obligation sera à la charge des
employeurs comme c'est le droit
actuellement pour les autres vaccins
obligatoires
nous demandons donc une accélération la
vaccination des soignants et tous les
indicateurs sont au vert qui nous
remontent des ehpad et des hôpitaux
montrant qu'il y a une très forte
mobilisation de celles et ceux qui
avaient décidé d'attendre et qui
aujourd'hui ont compris qu'on ne pouvait
plus attendre
en parallèle nous ne souhaitons pas
faire peser l'effort sanitaire
uniquement sur les soignants je tiens
une nouvelle fois à remercier pour leur
investissement c'est pourquoi nous avons
étendu le recours aux passes sanitaire
qui ne sera plus limité comme c'est le
cas actuellement au grand événement pour
les événements intérieurs extérieurs de
plus de 1000 personnes
l'extension du passé fera en plusieurs
étapes d'abord par décret à compter de
demain mercredi 21 juillet nous
abaissons le seuil de 1000 personnes à
50 dans l'ensemble des établissements
recevant du public ou le passé ni terre
est déjà en vigueur depuis le 30 juin
l'extension de l'application du pass
sanitaires à partir de 50 participants à
l'ensemble des rp concernera aussi tous
les rp qui rentre dans le champ des
loisirs défini par la loi actuelle
c'est-à-dire les parcs à thème
les établissements sportifs clos et
couvert les bowling les salles de jeu
des cinémas les théâtres les musées et
les monuments
enfin le passe à lithaire sera exigée à
partir de 12 ans et non plus 11 ans afin
de nous aligner et c'est tellement
logique sur l'âge d'ouverture à la
vaccination
donc les enfants de moins de 12 ans
pourront suivre leurs parents sans
évidemment qu'on leur demande de passes
sanitaires que nous prévoyons dans le
projet de loi maintenant c'est d'abord
une extension du pass au bar restaurant
au déplacement longue distance sur le
territoire national aux grands centres
commerciaux à l'exception des biens
essentiels évidemment aux visiteurs des
établissements accueillant des personnes
fragiles or les services d'urgence
s'agissant donc des grands centres je le
disais un seuil sera défini par décret
en garantissant l'accès aux biens et aux
services de première nécessité
l'objectif sera de définir le périmètre
de la mesure en tenant compte de
l'existence ou non d'alternative à
proximité raisonnable du centre pour
permettre à ceux qui refusent de
présenter un pass sanitaires
droit à l'entrée de disposer d'autres
options l'exigence de ce pass se fera
dès le premier entrant et concernera
également les mineurs à partir de 12 ans
le pass sanitaire sera également exigé
aux salariés des établissements recevant
du public visé ainsi qu'aux adolescents
mais à partir du 30 août prochain
uniquement pour les ados et les salariés
vous le savez à 7 passes sanitaire
s'ajoute un renforcement des sanctions
encourues en cas de manquement aux
obligations prévues
lorsqu'une obligation sur sanction c'est
plus une obligation et parce que nous
prenons ces mesures pour protéger les
français et permettre la vie la plus
normale possible dans notre pays avec la
circulation du virus
à titre d'exemple pour un client usager
en cas de manquement à la présentation
d'un pass sanitaire conforme une amende
forfaitaire de 135 euros pouvant
conduire en cas de verbalisation répété
à une peine de six mois d'emprisonnement
et 3750 euros d'amendé pour les
exploitants d'établissements recevant du
public
le défaut de contrôle des passagers
terre à l'entrée d'un événement ou d'un
erp et sera puni d'une amende de 1500
euros
et en cas de manquements répétés plus de
trois fois plus de trois fois
ça pourra aller jusqu'à un an de prison
et 9000 euros d'amande ou 45000 euros
d'amendé s'il s'agit d'une entreprise
le préfet pourra également prononcée par
arrêté la fermeture administrative des
établissements concernés
l'objectif je le redis c'est de limiter
l'impact d'une quatrième vague c'est de
ne pas avoir refermé ses établissements
pour l'ensemble des français
les scientifiques nous le dise si nous
fermions tous les établissements comme
nous l'avons fait pendant le confinement
pour tous les français
l'impact épidémique et sanitaire serait
le même que si nous fermions l'ensemble
de ces établissements pour les seuls non
vaccinés cette donnée-là est
fondamentale à appréhender
alors vous allez démarrer vos débats
pour finir nous allons renforcer les
mesures d'isolement déjà existantes et
nous allons les systématiser pour toute
personne testée positive au commis de 19
ces mesures ne concerner jusqu'à présent
que les voyageurs venant de l'étranger
désormais dès notification d'une
infection au co vides pour tout individu
sur le territoire national un isolement
de dix jours sera obligatoire
concrètement cela fonctionnera de la
manière suivante lors de la réalisation
d'un test les conditions d'isolement en
cas de résultats positifs seront
communiqués à chaque personne
dès la notification de la contamination
la personne concernée devra s'isoler
dans le lieu qu elle indiquera il sera
possible de demander au représentant de
l'état d'aménager ces heures de sorties
en raison de contraintes familiales ou
personnelles dûment justifiés ou de
définir des conditions d'hébergement
permettant d'assurer la sécurité des
personnes victimes de violences
conjugales
le juge des libertés et de la détention
pourra être saisi à tout moment pour
demander la main levée de la mesure où
le bénéfice d'aménagement qui aurait été
refusée par le préfet pour ce qui
concerne le suivi et le respect de la
mesure des contrôles à domicile ils
seront assurés par les forces de l'ordre
sur une amplitude horaire spécifique de
8h à 23h
en cas de non respect d'isolement les
sanctions seront de niveau
contraventionnelle les cas contacts ne
sont absolument pas concernés par ces
mesures d'isolement obligatoire qui ne
s'applique par définition coca positif
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
gouvernement vous présente des mesures à
nouveau exceptionnel
j'en ai confiance mais qui vise à
répondre à une situation qui menace de
devenir rapidement critique
ma position est claire elle est nette
elle est précise nous assumons ces
mesures qui envoie un message de fermeté
et de clarté pour une capacité à vivre
le plus normalement possible avec le co
vide
la vaccination est une chance la
vaccination est un droit mais ça peut
aussi devenir un devoir et même une
responsabilité
pas d'exception pas de passager
clandestin nous voulons du collectif du
collectif du collectif pour atteindre
l'immunité et se débarrasser du virus
le pastel iter et les mesures
d'isolement doivent être vus non pas
comme des contraintes mais comme des
équivalents de dispositifs médicaux
quand vous êtes malade est contagieux
votre médecin vous demande de rester
chez vous quand vous avez un arrêt de
travail votre arrêt de travail est
susceptible de contrôle et de sanction
c'est le cas orco vide
il ne faut pas nous nous méprendre ce
n'est pas le pas sali dairou la liberté
la question c'est le passe à lithaire ou
le confinement et je ne doute pas que
nous débattrons ensemble de ce qu'est la
liberté de ce qu'elle n'est pas comme
des millions d'élèves avant et après moi
j'ai dû lire jean jacques rousseau avec
plaisir et j'ai appris avec lui que la
liberté résider dans l'obéissance à la
loi concept prescrite nous voilà donc au
bon endroit puisque c'est ici vous allez
faire la loi
je vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
donc j'ai enregistré 18 questions si
vous souhaitez que le ministre puisse
vous répondre je vous demanderai de
limiter vos questions à une minute parce
qu'autrement on n'aura pas le temps de
réponse puisque
il est attendu aux questions au
gouvernement et il doit répondre à la
première question qu'on pourra même pas
déborder sur ce temps là donc la
première question sera posée par
monsieur thomas rudigoz pour le groupe
la république en marche
je vais faire une question par groupe
pour le voir oui merci maintenant le
président de monsieur le ministre va
être en fait très factuelle et très
technique j'en profite de votre présence
il ya un point qui m'a été interpellés
qui m'a été questionné par un salon
d'habitants de ma circonscription c'est
pour les salariés des établissements qui
à partir du 1er août devront avoir un
pass sanitaires pour les clients et
aussi donc pour les salariés étant donné
les délais actuellement de vaccination
vous le savez on est contraint alors
vous avez reporté au 30 août
l'obligation vaccinale pour ses
personnels salariés ce qui est une très
bonne chose
néanmoins il ya un petit décalage avec
finalement l'obligation qui concerne des
personnels soignants même si à partir la
promulgation de la loi ils auront des
obligations très fermé sur l'obligation
vaccinale pure et simple
elle sera au 15 septembre est ce que
monsieur le ministre on pourrait mettre
en conformité les deux statuts c'est à
dire ceux qui sont salariés de cafés de
restaurants de centres de loisirs de
centres commerciaux touché qui seront
concernés par cette nouvelle voie avec
la modalité qui concernera les maires
sont venus à partir du 15 septembre au
merci merci beaucoup monsieur eric diard
fourni républicain oui merci monsieur
ministre projet que nous discutons
aujourd'hui le huitième relatifs à la
crise sanitaire
évidemment l'arrivée du var yann delta
nous a tous pris de court et pourtant
nous étions avertis récit se passait au
royaume uni et ce qui me gêne dans dans
les premières lignes ce projet de loi
c'est la progression des mesures de
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
faisant passer cette sortie du 30
septembre 31 décembre
le parlement s'est prononcé et il a
souverainement beauté la fin de l'état
d'urgence a fait septembre cela fait
plus d'un an que nous vivons sous d'un
régime d'exception si la situation était
aussi grave qu au début du printemps le
comprendrais mais ce n'est plus le cas
je pense que l'on peut encore laisser la
fin de l'état d'urgence fixée au 30
septembre grâce à la vaccination
enfin ce ministre je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur la mise en place du
pass sanitaires
note en bas dans les bars dans les cafés
dans les restaurants en effet ils
devront contrôler les passes annie terre
de leurs clients vous savez comment il
ya une trafic de faux pas ce qui ce
secret et ses tenanciers de bars et de
restaurants ne sont pas des policiers
comme envisagé qu'il puisse contrôler
l'identité de leurs clients alors que ce
n'est pas le métier afin de s'assurer la
validité du pass and as beaucoup pour le
groupe modem madame jacques laforge
merci madame la présidente j'aurai une
question très rapide monsieur le
ministre
concernant les centres commerciaux les
grands centres commerciaux parce que
vous êtes passés sur la présentation
extrêmement rapidement est ce que vous
pourriez rentrer un peu plus en détail
pour vous nous expliquer comment est-ce
que ça va se dérouler le décret est ce
que effectivement les élus locaux est ce
que les préfets pourront aussi
intervenir notamment sur la question des
alternatives puisque vous en avez vous
avez évoqué ce point puisqu'il ya les
grands centres commerciaux et puis elle
est bien de première nécessité
donc comment accéder à ces biens de
première nécessité sans impasse avec un
passé ce que vous pouvez nous détailler
la mesure ministre je vous remercie
je vous remercie pour le groupe
socialiste ce si long terme ailleurs
merci madame la présidente mois notre
notre groupe considère que en fait
l'adhésion est difficilement en lien
avec la contrainte et nous regrettons
effectivement qu'une pédagogie en amont
n'est pas permis d'aboutir à plus
d'adhésion et de compréhension sur le
dispositif sanitaire qui nous est
proposé ici et qui n'est pas neutre
notre question est la suivante les
gestes barrière à raison de la montée de
la vaccination semble être oubliée du
dispositif il n'en est plus fait mention
et nous considérons pourtant que lorsqu
on est vaccinés on peut être contaminée
et contaminant est que l'utilité
peut-être du port du masque serait un
discours de vérité vis-à-vis des
citoyens qui s'engagent dans la
vaccination mais qui doivent néanmoins
et bien satisfaire aux exigences des
gestes barrières
je vous remercie pour le groupe agir
ensemble madame agnès firmin le bodo oui
merci madame la présidente
l'article 1 du pg elle prévoit que la
situation des personnes ne pouvant se
faire vacciner à cause de contre
indication médicale sera déterminé par
décret
concrètement quelles solutions avez-vous
apporté pour que ces personnes ne soient
pas mises à l'écart de la société
je vous remercie pour le groupe
udi monsieur brindeau et merci madame la
présidente bon en une minute il est
impossible de couvrir toutes les
questions et tout le champ du débat qui
va être le nôtre sur ce texte
évidemment dont je je limiterai mon
intervention à trois questions
un propos de dispositions qui sont
contenues dans le projet de loi
la première et qui a trait au pass and i
ter commenceront déterminer quels seront
les personnes habilitées à contrôler le
pass sanitaire en fonction des
établissements qui sont visés par par le
texte
deuxième question il s'agit là des
dispositions qui sont contenues dans
l'article qui sont qui concerne
l'obligation vaccinale
il est fait un moment donné un état de
la possibilité de rupture de contrat
lorsqu'une personne reste non vaccinés à
l'issue d'un délai
comment entendez-vous cette rupture de
contrat dans l'avant projet de loi y
avait pas il y avait le terme de
licenciement qui était indiquée est ce
que cette rupture de contrat est une
rupture de type de licenciement et dans
ce cas pour quel motif
dans le secteur privé et dans le secteur
public
est ce que on s'acheminerait vers une
radiation ou une autre type de mesures
est enfin dernière question
l'accompagnement économique des pertes
d'activités pour les établissements qui
seront touchés par le passé dit m merci
beaucoup pour le groupe la france
insoumise madame caroline fiat
merci madame la présidente vous nous
dites monsieur le ministre que 15% de la
population la plus fragile n'est pas
vaccinée pensez vous que ces 15% de la
population seront concernés par le passé
ni terre que vous appelez de vos voeux a
poussé à la vaccination
20 % des plus de 80 ans isolé et je
bouge aux pantins je pense qu'ils ne
vont ni au resto ni au cinéma
pensez vous que ces deux passes
sanitaires qui vont les amener à la
vaccination
que faire pour les amener à cette
vous n'avez pas parlé dans ce projet de
loi de là les verts allaient vers ces
personnes allaient vers la vaccination
pour ses 20% de plus de 80 ans qu'il
faut absolument protéger
à la veille d'une 4ème vague ensuite
pour les personnels soignants les fameux
40% qui ont attrapé le coc vide et qui
doivent attendre plusieurs mois avant
d'avoir droit aux vaccins qu'allez vous
faire de ces soignants qui ne pourront
pas travailler
car ils ont attrapé le coc vide sur leur
lieu de travail bien souvent merci
beaucoup pour le groupe liberté
territoire monsieur paul molac oui
madame la présidente je trouve quand
même dommage que nous n'ayons pas le
temps de nous appuyer sur une discussion
parce que nous sommes en train de mettre
en place quelque part une obligation de
vaccination et c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est important donc c'est
dommage qu'on n'ait pas le temps de
parler de ces questions de liberté parce
que ça me semble particulièrement
important et personnellement moi je suis
que ceux qui veulent être vaccinés soit
vacciné que les autres ne le sera pas
alors j'ai une question comment se
fait-il que finalement les soignants
soit si peu vaccinés alors que ce sont
les premiers concernés les souvent en
première ligne et que ce sont finalement
ceux qui connaissent peut-être mieux le
monde médical ça m'interroge
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a remarqué
par rapport à l'espagne à l'italie et
l'allemagne qu'on a eu un décrochage de
la vaccination à partir du premier
joueur en france et qui s'est terminée
par en fait qu'il y ait 10 % de
différence entre les vaccinés en france
et dans ces trois pays que j'ai cités
pourquoi la dernière chose c'est sur la
question du départ qu est l'attraction
parce que évidemment quand on va dans
ses parcs on y va en famille et de toute
façon on n'aura pas les moyens de
vacciner tout le monde avant la fin de
la période estivale
donc je vois pas comment on peut
fonctionner à moins de faire des tests
pcr tous les deux jours ce qui me paraît
quand même compliqué merci beaucoup
moins chers collègues on prend le temps
c'est une audition qui ne vaut pas
discussion générale nous aurons la
discussion générale à 17 heures et vous
aurez 5 minutes pour vous exprimer au
nom de votre groupe et après nous
prendrons le temps qu'il faudra pour
examiner les amendements qui ont été
déposés par tous les collègues ne vous
inquiétez pas vous savez que en
commission des lois vous avez toujours
la parole autant vous le souhaitez et
vous le savez monsieur le ministre pour
cette première série
deux questions oui c'est de répondre
avec mon débit mitraillette pour laisser
le plus de temps possible aux questions
pour thomas rudigoz en fait les
soignants ce député
les soignants à compter de la
promulgation de la loi et devront s'y
sont pas vaccinés produire un test tous
les deux jours donc ils sont pas vous
dites on traite pas les salariés des rp
comme des soignants
c'est même plutôt l inverse c'est à dire
que les soignants dès la promulgation de
la loi devront produire des tests pour
pouvoir aller travailler s'ils ne sont
pas vaccinés par contre au 15 septembre
il faut que tout le monde soit vacciné
sans quoi il peut y avoir des
dispositifs de contrôle et de sanction
ce que nous ne souhaitons évidemment pas
pour député diar la date nous repoussons
à ce n'est pas l'état d'urgence
on est sortis de l'état d'urgence sur
des buts et c'est là les mesures
transitoires de sortie d'état d'urgence
que nous prolongeons jusqu'à fin
décembre le souvenir des débats
hippiques que nous avons eue lors du
dernier texte savoir si c'était fin
septembre et octobre
je vous avais dit rendez moi rendez-moi
compte de cela contre amenés à se revoir
peut-être avant la fin de l'été c'était
au mois de mai et je n'ai pas eu
complètement tort donc là vous pouvez ne
pas me faire confiance
ou me faire confiance si je vous dis que
fin septembre sur le député nous aurons
encore besoin de mesures de gestion
ce sera pas finie donc on doivent
évidemment poussé jusqu'à fin décembre
je reviendrai autant de fois qu'il le
faudra vous savez maintenant que je
tiens ma parole pour la député jacques
et la forge pour les centres commerciaux
d'abord pourquoi pourquoi impasse
sanitaires pour les centres commerciaux
beaucoup des gros centres sont situés en
périphérie des grandes villes dans des
banlieues
là où on a aussi des taux de couverture
vaccinale qui sont parfois plus faibles
et là on va voir une concentration
population importante notamment les
week-ends notamment les week-ends et
donc si on voit que ça flambe et qu'on
n'a pas de passé à lithaire pour rentrer
dans ses grands centres
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va les
fermer est ce qu'on veut c'est éviter de
fermer la logique du passé à lithaire
retenez bien ça c'est pas c'est pas une
carotte ou un bâton pour la vaccination
la logique du pass à lithaire c est ce
qu on ferme où est-ce qu'on vous laisse
ouvert pour les gens qui ne risque pas
de se contaminer ou de contaminer les
autres et donc on a besoin d'intégrer
les centres commerciaux c'est le décret
qui va définir probablement des surfaces
supérieures à vingt mille mètres carrés
on fera évidemment des exemptions pour
les pour les biens de première nécessité
et vous avez raison de souligner il y
aura une concertation préfets élus
locaux pour chacun de ses centres mais
entre 300 et 400 de mémoire de manière
on vérifiera les zones de chalandise
pour vérifier qu'on n'est pas en train
de mettre les gens dans la
difficultés pour la députée cécile
intermédiaire les médecins des gestes
barrières il est tellement important que
c'est aussi l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai dit aux députés diar
qu'on doit prolonger les mesures
dérogatoires de sortie d' état d'urgence
sanitaire ce nom peut plus imposer donc
évidemment qu'on a besoin de ces gestes
barrières et des mesures barrières dans
la période
pour la députée firmin le bodo oui c'est
par décret qu'on va traiter la question
des rares situations qui ne qui empêche
d'accéder à la vaccination est donc se
traduit par des crèmes on aura le débat
je pense dans l'hémicycle le député
brindeau qui contrôle le pass les
exploitants c'est eux qui décident qui a
la responsabilité c'est le cas
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
donc ça ne change pas la règle reste la
même et en cas de rupture de contrat je
vous confirme qu'il ya ou licenciements
ou radiation des cadres pour motif
haddock tel qu'il existe dans la loi
pour la députée fiat pour vacciner les
plus fragiles
on n'a pas besoin d'une loi pour faire
durer les verts ont fait dû aller vers à
fond les ballons depuis des mois madame
la députée non d'accord mais là ma
députée s'était bien c'est que la grande
zone humide on vous dit quelque chose
c'est toujours non mais on continue de
vous répondre
malgré tout parce que c'est la
démocratie oui on fait du aller vers
madame la députée vous avez des équipes
des ars vous avez l'assurance maladie
vous avez des 900 associations vous avez
laissé 16 vous avez les communes les
départements on a des bus qui vont dans
le au pied des tours on vaccine dans les
centres commerciaux on envoie des bons
on appelle les gens plus d'un million et
demi d'appel durée moyenne de l'appel 20
ou 25 minutes pour discuter avec les
gens essaient de les convaincre
on fait toutes ces démarches allaient
vers évidemment vous avez raison de dire
qu'elles sont importantes elles sont
elles sont la règle on n'a pas besoin de
loi pour ça on les poursuit mais
abandonnée c'est comme quand j'entendais
n'y a pas eu assez de pédagogie donc on
va obliger les gens à vacciner
maintenant s il suffisait d pédago pour
que les gens aient la démarche de
vacciner on aurait pu longtemps on
n'aurait pas voté il ya trois ans
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
nourrissons contre 11 maladie dont on
envoyer la résurgence dans la société
alors que ça faisait des décennies qu'on
vaccine est donc et puis vous avez posé
la question d'aidés soignants qui ont
attrapé le coc vide et qui donc ne
peuvent pas tout de se faire vacciner
mais si vous avez une copie d'entre 11
jours et six mois la règle ne change pas
vous avez ce certificat qui vous permet
d'exemption à la vaccination qui nous
exempte pas à vie mais dans cette
période là qui vous exemple évidemment
de devoir présenter les choses qui sont
on est con si l'on considère que vous
avez des anticorps sur le
le député mona que j'entends monsieur
molac j'entends et quand vous dites les
soignants ce sont ceux qui savent le
mieux et qui sont le moins vacciner
donc on va convaincre pour suivre ce
raisonnement par l'absurde pardon mais
on en a l'habitude
plus de 90 % des médecins sont vaccinés
plus de 85% des pharmaciens sont
vaccinés on a une difficulté de
vaccination chez les aides soignants
chez des ice h chez parfois des salariés
non soignants qui portent pas forcément
la blouse dans les établissements de
santé
je vous pose la question monsieur le
député qui est à même de dire si un
vaccin fonctionne entre un médecin et
partout malgré tout le respect que j'ai
pour pour des salariés non soignant de
l'établissement hospitalier
je pense que vous avez la réponse à
votre question donc la question de la de
savoir si les soignants sont eux mêmes
porteurs du discours pro vaccinale ceux
qui ont accès et qui ont appris cela oui
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument
qu'on accompagne les soignants moi je ne
peux pas comprendre qu'ils aient des
ehpad dans lesquelles vous y est presque
100% 100% des salariés qu'ils soient
vaccinés et d'autres vous soyez à 15%
je vous dirais je vous dire un truc
c'est pas un microclimat c'est qu'il ya
un problème dans l'établissement parfois
que des leaders d'opinion qui sont comme
ça contre le vaccin et qui décourage les
autres et parfois vous avez des leaders
d'opinion qui croient en la science et
qui conseille et qui oriente et qui
accompagne c'est évidemment cela que
nous voulons privilégier jusqu'au 15
septembre
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
deuxième série de questions pour
commencer militia sur le groupe la
république en marche
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre l'avait dit la quatrième vague
de lakovic 19 et là on sait la
vaccination sauf des millions de vies
elle contient maîtrise les épidémies
nous pouvons laisser personne dira le
contraire
la réalité des faits et la
incontournable la réalité des faits est
une forteresse imprenable en france de
façon singulière à travers le monde aux
vaccins sont aujourd'hui obligatoire
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire de nos
connaissances scientifiques et de
l'esprit de la france monsieur le
ministre vous comprenez ainsi ma
question pourquoi ne pas rendre
obligatoire le vaccin contre la copie de
19 pour tous les français de plus de 12
ans merci je vous remercie pour le
groupe l'est républicain monsieur xavier
breton
merci madame la présidente
oui mais monsieur milices j'avais même
la même interrogation comment collègues
lac sur le personnel soignant qui était
quand même confronté en première ligne
avec toute la réalité des premières
vagues et tous les drames qui sont faits
et qui aussi a des compétences alors
j'entends bien qu'elles sont pas de
niveau des médecins
enfin j'avoue que votre post m'interroge
quand même sur la vision de tous
personnels soignants qui lui même est
fait part de réticences par rapport à la
vaccination et qui doivent nous
interroger je suis dit personnel
soignant ni de formation médicale mais
en tout cas ça mettait en jeu deuxième
point vous vous disiez dans votre
introduction de ce ministre c'est une la
vaccination c'est une chance et un droit
c'est de voir ça peut être une
responsabilité
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord sur
cette conception la question c'est la
responsabilité en cas de problème si la
vaccination devait à court moyen terme
poser des problèmes sur une échelle un
peu plus grands qui assumera la
responsabilité
ce ne sont pas les laboratoires qui font
les vaccins est ce que ça sera l'état je
pense que c'est important dans une
logique d'obligations de vaccination que
la responsabilité aille de pair et dire
s'il ya des problèmes qui assumera cette
responsabilité est ce que c'est les
citoyens qui devront du mais ça m'énerve
à la double peine
ou est-ce que c'est l'état qui va suivre
merci pour le groupe modem se fit vigier
oui merci à mme la présidente ce
ministre les dictionnaires objectifs
ambitieux 15 septembre l'ensemble du
personnel soignant qui sera vacciné il
ya une forte demande à l'heure actuelle
de vaccination ce que pouvait nous
garantir tous les moyens seront bien au
rendez vous tentons en vaccins qu'en
matière organisationnelle
qu'est-ce qui a déjà beaucoup de tension
dans les centres la seconde chose à et
des ehpad sur les sanctuaires très bien
pourquoi ne pas avoir fait le choix de
vacciner les résidents et les vacciner
les futurs visiteurs parce que ils
devront uniquement fournir un pass
d'accès na li la troisième question
rapide
pourquoi ne pas avoir souhaité une
harmonisation entre la date de
vaccination obligatoire pour les
personnels le 15 septembre et le pass
sanitaires alors qu'il sera avec l'ami
au 31 août pour les salariés des bars et
des restaurants
parce que j'ai pas sur le t1 moyens me
semble-t-il important pour les
encourager à se vacciner
merci merci beaucoup pour le groupe
socialiste madame lamia el
h merci beaucoup madame la présidente
très rapidement parce que une minute
c'est court et je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'avoir le débat sur le fond
un peu plus tard et j'aurai l'occasion
d'exposer notre position sur la question
de vaccination obligatoire bien loin de
la caricature que vous avez commencé un
petit peu à andré s'aimer mais j'y
reviendrais juste après jeu sur la
question des chiffres que vous avez
évoqué moi j'aimerais une petite
précision sur l'action la disponibilité
des doses et par avoir la question de
l'instauration du pass sanitaires si je
me réfère aux données publiques que
qu'on a pu partager au 15 juillet il
semblerait qu'il restait à peu près 7,3
millions de doses et si on fait un
calcul assez basique à savoir qu'on est
entre 700 et 900 mille doses jour en
dosant et 2,2 depuis l'allocution du
président de la république
un calcul assez grossier donnerait en
gros huit jours de disponibilité par
rapport à nos stocks et ça nous inquiète
un petit peu parce que par ailleurs il
ya certaines ars qui commence à partager
des messages à destination des acteurs
locaux demandant la suspension ou
l'arrêt des prises de rendez vous qu'en
est-il pourriez vous nous préciser si
réellement on aura les moyens de
permettre à tous ceux qui le souhaitent
de bénéficier de cette vaccination
je remercie monsieur mathieu orphelin
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre comment renouer le dialogue
avec ceux qui se posent des questions je
parle pas des anti vaccins mais de ceux
qui se posent des questions de bonne foi
j'avais dire et on en rencontre beaucoup
dans les circonscriptions
que pensez vous de l'idée d'un courrier
envoyé par l'assurance maladie à tous
les a toutes les citoyens leur proposant
une consultation gratuite chez le
médecin non pas pour se faire vacciner
vacciner mais pour dialoguer et le
médecin traitant c'est souvent le
personnel de santé car la grande
confiance des personnes et puis deuxième
point sur la date du 30 août
je vois dans le maine et loire
aujourd'hui il ya des centres de
vaccination qui ont des places
disponibles première place le 6 août
mais il y en a d'autres dans les zones
plus rurales où les premiers rendez-vous
sont le 20 ou le 22 août
pour commencer un cycle de vaccination
est ce que dans ces cas là on peut pas
penser à une évolution de la date du 30
août vers le 15 septembre dans des
conditions dans des zones où
effectivement
les premiers rendez-vous sont
aujourd'hui pour le 20 août merci
beaucoup ludovic mendes merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre
dès demain il faudra présenter un passé
et terre pour accéder aux lieux de
loisirs de culture rassemblant plus de
50 personnes puis à partir du 1er août
les restaurants bars ou centres
commerciaux
dans ce contexte je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur les personnes
atteintes d'une affection de longue
durée les personnes immunodéprimées
celles présentant un risque allergique
et plus globalement l'ensemble des
personnes pour lesquelles l'injection
d'un vaccin présente une
contre-indication médicale déjà atteint
par une maladie incurable et handicapant
au quotidien ces personnes se verrait
subir une double peine on ne pourront
plus se rendre dans les lieux de culture
et de loisirs à la seule condition de
réaliser un test de dépistage toutes les
48 heures c'est pourquoi monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais savoir si le
passager terre pourrait faire l'objet
d'aménagements pour l'ensemble des
personnes ne pouvant pas à date se faire
vacciner contre la copie 19 pour des
raisons médicales
je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur bah là non merci madame la
prison moi j'ai une question très
concrète sur les secteurs touristiques
et est le mien en particulier en
bretagne on est en plein milieu de la
crise la crise
oui la crise aussi mais de la saison
touristique et je voulais savoir comment
on va pouvoir accompagner un certain
nombre de personnes et ça dépasse
peut-être le champ de votre ministère
monsieur le ministre sur les sur les
mesures d aide puisque vous avez
certains secteurs et je pense par
exemple au secteur aux activités de
plein air les parcs de paix n'est requis
qui ont aujourd'hui des baisses une
monumentale de réservation et comment on
va pouvoir les accompagner et comment on
va pouvoir faire pour que ces gens
puissent continuer à survivre ils ont
fait des efforts pendant toute la
période précédant la crise ils ont
réussi à ouvrir et aujourd'hui ils sont
dans des situations assez difficile
quelle mesure pour les accompagner je
vous remercie monsieur charles de
courson
monsieur ministre quatre questions
première question ne craignez vous pas
que la suspension automatique de
l'activité des personnels de santé et
assimilés sans rémunération
ceux qui refusent la vaccination
n'entraîne la fermeture de certains
services dans les hôpitaux et les
cliniques et comment s'applique le texte
pour les personnels libéraux
deuxième question est il raisonnable
pour les restaurants les bars de traiter
les terres
comme l'intérieur de ces établissements
troisième question y at il pas en l'état
actuel du projet de loi un risque de
radicalisation de la minorité qui
refusent la vaccination et dernière
question le gouvernement at il les
moyens de contrôler la correcte
application de ce texte en l'état je
vous remercie monsieur et zèle pour les
républicains
oui merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre il y a eu ces
derniers jours un certain nombre des
changes sur la question des vaccins les
essais de phase iii sont toujours en
cours pour les vaccins concernant la
qu'ovide or si vous prenez la
législation en vigueur et plus
précisément le règlement européen 530
6-2 114 d'après ce règlement lorsque les
vaccins sont en phase 3 il faut un
consentement libre et éclairé des
personnes qui se font vacciner et donc
pouvez vous nous indiquer juridiquement
comment vous allez procéder pour
contourner cette règle de droit qui doit
s'appliquer à tous les vaccins qui sont
encore en phase iii et pour ceux qui
arrivent à échéance le plus tôt ce sera
pour le 31 décembre de cette année je
remercie monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie madame l'éthicien avia oui
merci à la présidente monsieur mines et
je voulais vous interroger sur deux
points relatifs au passé ni terre le
premier a déjà été évoqué c'est la
question la question des terrasses
puisque l'avis du conseil d'état
on dit bien qu' il nous faut agir de
manière proportionnée et notamment
s'assurer que nos concitoyens n'est pas
à présenter à leur identité à de trop
nombreuses entreprises dans une journée
aussi parce que les différentes
dispositions que nous avons prises dans
le cadre de la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire tendent à confirmer que les
risques de propagation du virus sont
moins importants à l'extérieur et
notamment le fait de ne pas porter de
masque lorsqu'on a un extérieur et de
pouvoir notamment
consommer
une boisson à emporter sur un banc qui
serait à côté d'une terrasse éphémère
donc pensez vous qu'il soit judicieux
d'étendre le pass sanitaires à ses
terrasses et très rapidement mon second
point il est indiqué dans le texte que
les salariés n'ont pas les salariés mais
toutes les personnes qui interviennent
dans ces lieux devant avoir un pass
sanitaires est-ce que cela vise bien
toutes les personnes y compris non
salariés y compris les prestataires sous
traitants etc qui seraient amenés à
intervenir dans ces lieux
merci je vous remercie madame emilie
carew s'était inscrite elle est ce
qu'elle est dans la salle n'ont donc on
passe à la suivante madame o pelt
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre ma question porte sur la
possibilité d'étendre la durée de
validité du test pcr aujourd'hui impasse
sanitaire requiert la preuve d'un tests
virologiques effectuées dans les 48
heures ce délai peut être contraignant
en particulier pour les personnes qui
travaillent dans le tourisme culture les
soignants la restauration et qui n'ont
pas complété leur parcours vaccinale
pouvons nous donc étendre ce délai en
toute sécurité à 72 heures
comme par exemple c'est le cas pour
certains départs à l'étranger
par ailleurs par ailleurs nous pourrions
imaginer aussi prévoir des doses
supplémentaires pour les pharmaciens
alors général une maille le territoire
de façon cohérente avec les
restaurateurs et les lieux de culture
donc nous pourrions leur permettre de
prioriser la vaccination de ces mêmes
personnels la merci je vends merci j'ai
encore trois questions et je n'en prends
plus madame ménard
merci madame la présidente ça va être
rapide parce qu'un certain nombre ont
déjà été posées mais moi aussi j'avais
une question sur le nombre de doses de
vaccins disponibles pour savoir si
l'obligation vaccinale au fond de
l'incitation vaccinale très forte et
crédible par rapport au nombre de doses
disponibles aujourd'hui
deuxième question comment est-il
sera-t-il possible de contrôler le pass
sanitaire en extérieur nombreuses
préoccupations ça a été dit mais de la
part des des terrasses de café qui qui
pense que ça va être absolument
impossible à contrôler
troisième question qui n'a pas été posée
c'est l'exemple des touristes étrangers
je pense notamment à des couples qu'ils
sont venus qui sont arrivés en france
avant la conférence du président de la
république et qui ont déjà été vaccinés
dans leur pays mais dont le passeport
vaccinale n'est pas reconnue avec le qr
code et qui donc ne vont pas bénéficier
du pass sanitaire parce qu'elles ont au
vison pour pour que ce soit reconnue il
faut qu'ils aillent ce soit chez le
médecin soit se faire inscrire sur
ameli.fr sauf qu'ils n'ont pas forcément
de numéros de sécurité sociale français
quatrième question les répercussions et
quand même merci jeu juste fini avec ça
les répercussions économiques j'étais
hier soir avec le cirque gruss
ce soir ils ont 700 entrées réservé dans
leur cirque demain ça tombe à 200 ça va
poser un vrai problème de viabilité
économique merci beaucoup madame ménard
eric bouillard
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre alors que les salariés
travaillant dans les rp dans le champ
des loisirs disposeront d'une dérogation
au pass sanitaires vous avez vous bien
bien nous préciser à nouveau que les
l'ensemble des bénévoles associatifs
pourront bénéficier de cette même
dérogation des en fin de deuxième
question la suite d'un cluster détecter
ces derniers jours dans une discothèque
à bordeaux le contrôle de passage était
ressembler y être bien à effectuer mais
vraisemblablement le contre la
vérification d'identité a été beaucoup
plus fait de manière beaucoup plus l'est
donc pouvez vous comment comptez vous
demain à renforcer l'obligation de
vérification d'identité à l'entrée des
sites concernés par le passé ni terre je
vous remercie madame laure oh oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
l'opposition légitime que suscite une
telle extension de la vaccination pour
certains corps de métier trop souvent
catégorisé comme une hostilité à toute
forme de vaccination étant moi même
vacciné depuis plusieurs mois je suis
beaucoup plus à l'aise pour m'élever
contre ces obligations des questions
légitimes se pose sur l'extension du ps
annie terre une de mes questions
concerne les personnels soignants
comment feront par exemple les femmes
appartenant au corps médical qui sera
enceinte qui aurait un projet de
grossesse en effet je rappelle que ce
qui nous manque principalement c'est un
recul sur les enfants les immunodéprimés
les femmes enceintes si elles refusent
seront elles excluent de leur service ce
n'est pas le cas comment le gouvernement
peut-il tenir compte de ces situations
singulières ma deuxième question portait
sur les restaurateurs et les passes
sanitaires pour les étrangers les
restaurateurs ne veulent pas faire les
gendarmes
aujourd'hui les français les françaises
n'ont plus confiance et je pense que ce
qui est important madame fiat en a parlé
vous en avez parlé également c'est
redonner la confiance aux français et
aux françaises sur la vaccination
à l'heure actuelle mais je vous remercie
et pour terminer monsieur cyrille isaac
sibille merci à la présidente monsieur
ministre facile ibm i on a un triptyque
pour faire face les gestes barrière
deuxième chose isolement troisième chose
la vaccination par rapport à l isolement
donc c'est la première fois qu'on avance
un petit peu par rapport à l' isolement
et quelque part pour nous c'est un peu
nouveau
comment est ce que vous pensez et
d'immenses tissement doit se faire on
sait que si elle est ses deux domiciles
on sait que les plus grandes
continuation soit intrafamiliales donc
est ce qu il yad autres deux oppositions
d'autres possibilités par rapport à ça
d'autres choses et timo on pourrait le
faire qui m'ont pas pris le contrôle
précis par rapport aux séries la
préfecture est-ce pourquoi pas imaginer
qu'un service sanitaire via un témoin
les rs ou la cnam à sanitaire qui puisse
faire ce contrôle est par ces contrôles
préfectorale je vous remercie
une petite question madame sereinement
aux bornes
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
bonjour monsieur le ministre est
rapidement est-ce qu'on peut envisager
de raccourcir le délai de génération du
pass vaccinale après la deuxième
injection c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les générer en sept jours ce qui va
immanquablement provoquer des
difficultés au regard des dates et des
créneaux de délais qu'on a pour
l'obtention de la deuxième vaccination
quid des patients non vaccinable moi je
serais favorable à ce que ce soit
seulement des spécialistes qui puisse
rendre un certificat de non vaccination
est la troisième question concerne les
obèses en population générale dont on
sait qu'aujourd'hui 1 seulement sur deux
est vacciné et ce sont eux les clients
de la réanimation
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
ok j'ai seize questions qui s'ajoute aux
7 d'avancé c'est tout à fait normal
je ne répondrai pas complètement à
toutes les questions vous connaissez ma
capacité à être bavard il prendre du
plaisir mais là on a dix minutes avant
les questions au gouvernement et je
passerai tout le temps qu'il faut avec
vous en commission ce soir et et en sort
publique à l'assemblée de main sur la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous
d'abord je voulais dire à madame et la
rage mais les partis mais les ménages
mais j'aurais dû répondre madame chan a
semé jédir madame allait racheter disait
que j'avais déjà caricaturer la position
du groupe socialiste les visages étaient
la radio ce matin j'ai plutôt salué ce
qui consiste à déposer des amendements
constructif même quand ça va pas dans le
sens du gouvernement pourvu qu'on en
débatte
je me suis juste étonnée que lors des
consultations des groupes politiques
aucun est mis sur la table la
vaccination obligatoire de toute la
population mais chacun est libre de
changer et d'évoluer dans son antre
jugement et donc j'ai certes
certainement pas caricaturer la position
du groupe socialiste sujet même plutôt
dit l'inversé
cela étant je suis pas favorable à la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous
d'abord n'allez pas imaginer que si la
vaccination était obligatoire pour tous
sur le pad pas solitaire on en débattra
mais ces vaccinations obligatoires pour
tous et pascal iter ce que vous proposez
or j'ai vu dans votre communiqué que
vous dites à la place du passager terre
veut la vaccination bat non parce que le
temps qu'on est la vaccination
opérationnel pour tous
s'ils voulaient pas qu'on ferme les bars
les restos les commerces etc il faudra
bien toute façon mettre en place le pass
sanitaires donc les débats sont
légitimes ce n'est pas la position du
gouvernement ce n'est pas la position
nous défendrons dans le dans le débat et
qu'on fait à l'intervention du président
de la république sur la responsabilité
donc là on va monsieur brou monsieur le
député breton je pense que vous êtes
parfaitement au courant mais vous poser
la question néanmoins la responsabilité
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques est
évidemment totalement impliqué en cas de
vice de procédure de défaut de
fabrication de vice de forme
comme pour tout médicament ça c'est des
fake comme on en lit depuis des mois on
faisait des mois que les gens ont
compris que c'étaient des feuilles qui
est ensuite c'est la responsabilité de
l'état en cas d'accident thérapeutique
d'aléa thérapeutique avec le ce qu'on
appelle le fond avec le fonds de
dédommagement que l'oniam ya aucune
responsabilité à la charge des patients
j'en profite pour redire pour la 58e
fois mais je vois que ça continue de
remonter sur les réseaux qu'il n'y a
aucune décharge de responsabilité que
qui que ce soit et amené à signer quand
il se fait vacciner
c'est faux c'est mensonger c'est
factuellement faux
on nous fait en aucun cas signer une
décharge disant qu'en cas de pépin c'est
pour votre pomme c'est faux c'est un
problème avec le produit c'est le
laboratoire si un problème avec la
vaccination c'est l'état et vous ne
signez aucune décharge ça va mieux en le
disant sur la question de savoir s'il ya
suffisamment de vaccins et les stocks
etc
d'abord il y a oui plusieurs millions de
doses de vaccins mais qui vivent ce qui
ce qui s'arrachent comme des petits
pains si je puis dire et c'est tant
mieux
était d'autant plus tant mieux qu'on a
des livres ayant toutes les semaines
plusieurs millions de doses de vaccin au
lieu de nous sont livrés chaque semaine
et donc nous continuons à alimenter les
centres la médecine de ville
nous augmentons jeu puis qui a posé la
question les livraisons aux pharmaciens
on va donner de la visibilité sur les
trois semaines à l'ensemble des libéraux
pour qu'ils puissent vacciner encore
plus intensément qu'auparavant sur
députés matthieu orphelin
c'est pas un courrier qu'on en voit on
envoie un courrier des sms on appelle et
on rappelle toutes les personnes qui
sont au dessus de la tranche d'âge pour
le pour les risques et toutes les
personnes qui ont des comorbidités on va
aller chercher la démarche d'aller vers
c'est vraiment con etc on les mobilise
au maximum ensuite il ya plusieurs
interventions vous l'avez fait et
d'autres députés l'ont fait sur la date
pourquoi pas le pourquoi le 30 août et
pas le 15 septembre pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne fait pas en octobre ista les
amis je vous dire si on pouvait ne pas
mettre de pas sanitaires on mettrait pas
de passes annie terre et vous connaissez
ma position intime que j'ai dit devant
vous et j'ai rappelé à plusieurs
reprises
si on en est au point où on vous demande
de mettre en place un pass sanitaire
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas le temps et
qu'on n'a pas le choix et que si on
repousse alors qu'il la souplesse dans
l'application du pass pour tenir compte
des contraintes des uns et des autres
dont acte c'est normal mais si on
commence à repousser ça on sera
complètement sous la vague au moment où
on se parle je ne sais pas pour vous
faire peur mais pour vous dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont et en
transparence je viens d'avoir un instant
là les chiffres de santé publique france
du jour hier dans notre pays a eu 18
mille malades diagnostiqués 18 mille
malades 18000 on est à 150 %
d'augmentation sur une semaine on est
déjà en train d'atteindre des niveaux
d'exposants ciel de la courbe de
contamination qu'on a connue quand on
était dans la dynamique très forte
deuxième et troisième vague donc quand
on est à dix huit mille malades
aujourd'hui qu'on se pose la question de
savoir si les mesures de protection au
lieu de les mettre dans cinq semaines on
peut les mettre dans cette
moi j'ai envie de vous dire si on
pouvait mettre les mesures de passes 2
sans même attendre une loi je me suis je
le ferai mais la démocratie lit-on ce
qu'elle est je la respecte
il nous faut passer par la loi attend la
promulgation la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel etc
mais n'allez pas imaginer une seconde
que la question du délai non mais non
mais n'imaginez pas une seconde que la
question du délai ce soit une question
de confort évidemment que c'est embêtant
pour tout le monde n'a pas solitaire
c'est pas ça fait passer en société mais
abordés on va avoir des dizaines de
milliers de malades au quotidien
donc je dire il faut réagir maintenant
sinon vous serez les premiers à nous
dire qu'on a réagi trop tard sur les
raisons médicales de ne surtout si vous
interrompez sinon je peux arrêter
monsieur débuté les raisons médicales de
ne pas se faire vacciner j'aurai
l'occasion je crois de répondre à une
plus âgés tout à l'air dont je réserve
la réponse pour les députés par pas
respect sur la question des aides
économiques
évidemment on en parle avec bruno le
maire avec avec le secrétaire d'état
alain griset mais il y aura des mesures
de soutien partout c'est nécessaire on
n'a jamais les sens on a jamais laissé
tomber qui que ce soit en pays de caux
vide comme hors cac decaux vide
si le député de courson des départs de
soignants j'ai déjà dit que j'y croyais
pas je n'y crois pas et d'ailleurs il ya
énormément de dealers vaccinale c'est
pas parce que vous voyez un infirmier
une aide-soignante qui fait une vidéo
pour dire en pleurant qu'elle va quitter
son boulot parce que le vaccin à la
vapeur etc etc que ça veut dire que
c'est un mouvement collectif
c'est faux ça s'appelle de la propagande
je le déplore il n'y a pas de départ et
ça n'a pas été le cas non plus dans les
autres pays qui autour de nous on fait
la vaccination obligatoire des soignants
et moi je souhaite vraiment qu'on
conforte les soignants dans leur
exercice qu'on les protège et qu'on leur
permette de protéger leurs patients sur
le débat sur les terrasses et le pass
sanitaire avec le variant et avec la
contagiosité de ce variant la
comptabilité ce variant si vous êtes
rassemblés dehors sans masque il ya des
risques de contagiosité qu'on n'avait
pas forcément auparavant par ailleurs
contrôler le pass sanitaires à
l'intérieur d'un restaurant ou d'un bar
sans contrôle à l'extérieur ça veut dire
on bloque l'accès aux toilettes aux
salles de bains comment empêcher gens de
rentrer et de sortir dans le restaurant
et dans le bar honnêtement si vous
voulez un dispositif qui soit
dysfonctionnelle retirer le pass des
terrasses si vous voulez un truc qu'il
soit fonctionnel
soyons carré et franchement je préfère
encore une fois qu'on soit contraignant
et qu'on accompagne évidemment les bars
et les restaurants dans la mise en place
du dispositif plutôt qu'on est obligé de
les fermer faute de pouvoir faire
respecter les règles sanitaires
sur le lait sur le vaccin qui est en
phase iii alors depuis qu'elle est hélas
non alors monsieur paresse et un don
mais alors on parle de la vaccination
pour tous ressortir les arguments sur un
vaccin qui est en phase iii accompagné
compagnies comme si c'était un bac 5 et
pas de recul je vous le dis hein c'est
votre droite parlementaire
je trouve pas ça très responsable voilà
je vous le dis le vaccin il est éprouvée
il ya 3 milliards plus de 3 milliards
d'humains qui ont été vaccinés plus de
bientôt 60 millions de français ont été
vaccinés on entend tout et n'importe
quoi sur ce vaccin
regardez ce que dit la science regarder
ce que dit les données des laboratoires
les données des organismes publics
français européens américains et
internationaux sur ses vaccins
depuis maintenant des mois de recul que
nous avons et oui nous sommes en
conformité avec la loi en faisant une
obligation vaccinale sinon nous ne
ferions pas et sinon conseil d'état nous
aurions pas dit oui mais c'est de
débuter ensuite sur les la question des
sous traitants pour la député habia ils
sont pris effectivement dans la
vaccination quand ils interviennent en
établissement de santé où intervient en
établissement médico social
oui j'ai dit répondu pour les doses en
plus pour les pharmaciens et sur les
conditions d'isolement elles peuvent se
faire à domicile mais comme c'était le
cas auparavant ils peuvent se faire
aussi en hôtel ou en structure adaptée
si les gens ne se ne peuvent pas remplir
les conditions d'un isolement safe pour
eux et pour leur entourage
on maintient les cellules territoriales
d'appui l isolement on maintient les
visites à domicile des infirmières
on maintient l'apport administratif le
soutien humain qu'on ne met en place
depuis un an et demi dans notre pays on
est l'un des seuls pays pour ne pas dire
le seul à le faire
malheureusement ça ne suffit pas il ya
des taux de respect d'isolement chez les
cas positifs qui sont faibles parfois
très faible parfois même minoritaire
c'est à dire vous avez parfois des ide
dans des études qu'on a des ars et quand
on fait des appels chez les gens se rend
compte qu'il ya moins de la moitié des
patients positifs qui sont joignables
chez eux au moment où ils sont censés
l'être
c'est ça le débat sur l'obligation
d'isolement à nouveau c'est pas de gaîté
de coeur mais en donner si on veut s'en
sortir collectivement tourner la page du
coc vide il renvoie au virus
on est obligé de prendre des mesures
qu'il faut pour protéger les français je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre on
coule et que mes chers collègues on
reprend à 17h pour avec la discussion
générale en présence de brigitte
bourguignon et de cédric haut à tout à
l'heure